accompagner les victimes a signalé des
violences conjugales et porté plainte
avec cette signature l'hôpital de
rambouillet la police nationale des
yvelines renforcent leurs liens
l'occasion pour nous de formaliser ce
passage de rené ce passage de entre
équipes et qui permet aussi de donner
confiance à l'équipe à la victime de
pouvoir la soutenir lorsque la cette
démarche difficile de devoir porter
plainte
à un moment donné contre contre un
conjoint le cadre
de l'hôpital sera plus sécurisant pour
ces personnes le fait qu'on vienne
directement qu'on soit présentée par une
personne avec laquelle elles ont déjà un
contact privilégié voilà c'est quelque
chose de très positif sur le plan
psychologique pour les victimes
50 à 70 % des patients identifiés comme
victimes de violences par les urgences
de rambouillet ne porte pas plainte
pourra prendre nous mêmes le contact
avec la police pour donner le lieu le
lieu lors de rendez-vous à la dame où la
parole à la personne victime de
violences ça donne un attrait un peu
plus accueillant et chaleureux de sur la
démarche à faire elle les élèves
infirmiers et internes reçoivent depuis
le début de l'année une formation autour
de cette question
3000 cas de violence conjugale ont été
recensés dans les yvelines en 2020